ciao a tutti allora ci sono cose che
nella vita noi facciamo istintivamente
tipo per respirare venire freddo nati
fare la cacca nel verso giusto
altri invece deve o perlomeno dovrebbe
spiegarci qualcuno ora quello che
proprio non mi è chiaro che mai riuscito
a capire a chi decide cosa essenziale
sapere perché quanto pare è
importantissimo conoscere da capitale
della finlandia che tra parentesi a
helsinki
però dico nessuno ci insegna cose come
come fare la lavatrice e adesso il quale
è quella cosa che tutti fanno ma di cui
nessuno parla di affrontare l'argomento
però vorrei dire un paio di cose
scontate che però così scontate non sono
il preservativo non è un optional extra
lusso non va usato solo per occasioni
speciali tipo natale capodanno già
finale di un talent show ci sono anche
infezioni sessualmente trasmesse
un tipo la gonorrea o la sifilide magari
si è mai siete inciampati non lo so in
un enciclopedia medica
avrete visto che non sono malate con le
quali saltare il compito di matematica
quindi in breve il preservativo va usato
sempre dall'inizio alla fine di un
rapporto il sesso sicuro non è un
compito dell'uomo
io allora io mi girano a questo non lo
capirò mai perché se un uomo usa il
preservativo succede questo
tentativo anomino persone più
responsabili dell'anno un assegno a 100
euro mentre se la donna dove i
preservativi succede quest'altro fa
schifo
ragazzi se siete sessualmente attive
avere dei preservativi non vi renderà
delle ragazze di facili costumi bensì
delle persone intelligenti ha fatte
queste premesse parliamo adesso di cose
serie
molti di voi penseranno magari che non
esiste nulla al mondo di più virale di
un video di un gattino che cavalca un
cucciolo di foca e va a salvare un baby
unicorno vestito da kesha esiste una
cosa più virale dello pagan cam style
la clip è la cosa che mi fa verdi map
che il mondo si divide in due categorie
di ignoranti superficiali convinto prima
infatti un uso aveva qual è quella da
chi poi tutta la montatura per spillarci
soldi o ti cela affincheè perché ha
bisogno d'attenzione sepolte molte
briscola o gli ignoranti ossessivi le
ragazze che a sto per due anni non ce la
fa lo stesso
non so se sarai ragazzi ma siete sicuri
allora io lo so che per alcuni di voi il
web solamente quel posto dove ci si dà
appuntamento ai centri commerciali oddio
se guarda il sun sta nella mia borsa
oggi però vi assicuro che si può anche
parlare in maniera divertente di cose
serie il modo migliore per non
diffondere la tv è diffondere
l'informazione io solamente così cercato
di attirare la vostra attenzione il
resto dovete farlo voi dovete informarvi
io vi lascio intanto qua sotto un link
www.uniconsum.it ed il numero di
telefono verde aids e infezioni
sessualmente trasmesse 800 861061 grazie
a tutti quanti però è visto questo video
grazie anche cicciasan claudia per aver
preso parte io vi invito a cliccare
sulle facce di questi bei giovani the
show e the year e sam hardware che avete
visto qui ma che potete vedere anche nei
loro canali
ebbene ora certo online più fomenta
130.000 guglielmo si fa i capelli rosa
barbie anzi con ventate con che colore
volete che non si tiri dai capelli con i
giovani soprattutto sono dire questa
magia condividersi tutti punto
esclamativo questo